JOSCHA BACH: I think that religion probably
got us from the first million individuals—and
we had been at a million individuals for a
very long time in history—to the first one
hundred million.
And then this monotheistic religion, we got
to something like three hundred million.
And at the turn of the times at 1 BC we were
about three hundred million individuals.
And at the beginning of enlightenment, that
is somewhere around seven hundred AD approximately,
we were still four hundred million individuals.
And at this point we evolved in our culture
the ability to doubt.
We started doubting the religion.
And feudalism broke down as a result, and
we started building a modern much more productive
society.
This society got us two billions of individuals.
And then came the next revolution and the
twentieth century.
These were systemic societies.
Societies that were grown in the lab from
people that created ideologies.
Fascism, socialism, communism, market liberalism—These
were all things that people thought of and
invented and lapsed [??] and then implanted
them in societies.
Incidentally they all failed, and now in something
like a post-systemic age and we don’t really
know what works and what doesn’t work.
And when we want to describe our society we
sometimes use words like “resilience”
or “anti-fragility” and so on, which are
good words for muddling through.
Because we don’t really know how to organize
these societies in these days anymore.
It’s a very big problem; we need to deal
with this and many countries try to find different
answers to their problem.
So in a way this ability to program ideologies
and then project them onto people has been
a very big breakthrough for our species, and
important it is for mass media.
Mass media made the twentieth century possible,
because mass media synchronized the dreams
of large numbers of people, the ideas about
the world that they lived in.
And now due to social media, mass media has
lost much of their appeal.
You know that U.S. in some sense had two realities,
the CNN and the Fox News reality.
They were two narratives that were pretty
much incompatible.
Two stories that were being told to the people
and that affected their minds.
And now due to social media people have stopped
believing these media narratives to a very
large extent.
People believe random stuff basically.
That’s why we are so obsessed with the idea
of fake news, which is incidentally not the
propaganda that we are afraid of falling victim
to.
It’s a propaganda that we don’t want others
to infect.
Right?
Random bits of information, viral bits of
information that come from the internet and
that get people to disbelieve the same dream
that we are dreaming.
It’s actually very dangerous because it’s
going to splinter society into parts that
we don’t know how to glue together again.
I think that our brain is doing an amazing
thing that we don’t know how to do out there
in the real world.
Our brain is a self-organizing system that
processes information in a near-optimal way.
Sometimes you have defects where the brain
starts lying to itself, but mostly it doesn’t
happen.
Our nervous system is pretty accurate in the
sense that it doesn’t lie to itself very
much.
And the way we build our organization in the
world of our governments and so on, which
are in some sense the nervous systems of our
societies, they lie to themselves.
They are corrupted by local interests and
so on.
And we haven’t really found a way to build
information processing networks out in the
world that manage to be for the most part
always truthful and relevant.
And if we understand how our brain is pulling
this off to self-organize in such a way that
many, many small units can link up in a way
that organizes itself to do the best for that
particular organism, this is something that
we need to pull up in our societies too.
So I do think that insights from understanding
how our minds work and how our nervous systems
work are going to be very helpful in understanding
how to build better societies and better organizations.